are we going to cut the gap between the
second vaccination and the booster
well the jcvi are the only people who
can answer that question so what happens
is the jcvi obviously look at all the
data they look at loads of different
things and they basically make
trade-offs and sort of advise us so
they've advised us six months um we put
that place in pla yeah planning plays on
the 14th of september first jab booster
jab went in the arm on the 16th of
september
and of course they continually look at
the data but they're the only people who
can really answer this question but if
they advise us our job then is to get
ready obviously to uh to do whatever
they say so but at the moment it's six
months that's what we've been told and
that plan's in place and it's been in
place for about five weeks now chairman
of the health select committee uh jeremy
hunt of course former um health uh
secretary he's saying it should be cut
to five months
yeah well he's not on the jcvi i mean
there's a lot of people who have
opinions i mean we went through this
previously
and it's not unknown the jcvi have
changed at
periods of time and have reacted
but you know we have them in place for a
reason and you know we take their advice
so they will be looking every day all
the data and they will advise us but at
the moment it's six months and we are
fully arming everybody to try and get a
booster jab as quickly as possible what
about people who've had those two
vaccinations and then the efficacy of
that is waning and while they're waiting
for their next booster they get covered
well first of all there are people who
get covid um who have had two vaccines i
mean my parents actually had it uh the
other the other week um but of course
the vaccination has helped very much
with the symptoms and they said it was
like a heavy cold but we are concerned
always to make sure that we keep the
vaccine and what vaccine has been the
wall of defense we want to keep that
wall of defense which is why not only
are we having this big campaign today
we're telling everybody young people can
now go online as well and book so they
can just walk in and they can book with
their gp et cetera so and there's also
4.7 million people can actually go to
walk-in centres they can go now and book
so the booking system we've all been
using it wasn't there for young people
that's now live from today so they can
go online they can book a walk-in center
a gp all the places that you can go to
the vaccination centers that's from
today so we've got that ready for half
term and we'd urge all the young people
who haven't yet had their jobs to use
half term to get their jabs and then
we've got 4.7 million people who haven't
yet come forward for their first job
which is why we've got this campaign
saying please come forward and the
boosters are starting to to be rolled
out i think we had our biggest booking
day on wednesday this week i think 234
000 people booked their boosters so in
the next couple of weeks you'll see many
many many more people including those in
care homes having their booster job and
that's a vital part of our protection as
we see cases up to 50 000 yesterday
health secretary saying it could rise to
a hundred thousand cases a day why are
you not putting plan b in place now
because what we've got is we i mean
we've laid down plan a and plan b and
we've just started as i say five weeks
ago plan a the most important thing is
to do all the things i've just said get
that vaccine rolled out get those
boosters rolled out and of course we
have plan b there it is there for a
reason but right now we're really
focusing we know that the vaccine is
that is the best thing we can do we're
really focusing on making sure that that
is rolled out and you know if that's
that that should be successful we've
seen this we've been there before
you know we've also got anti-virals
coming that was another part of the
announcement so that is really the focus
to make sure that we're not going to
reduce the time to five months unless
the jcvi that's that's definitely true
and and also you know when we reopened
when we opened up on the 19th of july we
did that because we'd shown that we'd
broken the link between the cases and
the deaths and that's still the case you
know you the cases are high and
obviously we're not complacent about
that but the death rates still um are
very very low what's the downside to
compulsory mask wearing
i think there's a downside to many of
these things i mean you know some people
uh do find mass wearing difficult i it's
a personal choice but most of us are
wearing masks i mean on the tube most of
us are wearing masks i don't know if
you've seen that um and i think as more
and more it gets into winter i've had a
cough so i've been wearing a mask having
a cough is is socially unacceptable now
you know you feel terrible
so i think it is a personal choice many
many people do wear masks and many
people when you go out into meetings i
was in care homes yesterday everybody
was wearing masks
but it's about personal choice you know
we're not the sort of country that tells
you what you need to wear or you know it
is about personal choice we all know the
pros and cons of this we spent 18 19
months educating ourselves so we all
know what to do um and you know it's not
for the government really to mandate it
of course it's there as a backup um and
it is there as part of plan b but you
know we expect that people will do the
right thing and actually most people are
doing the right thing but the right
thing you can do right now is come
forward for your vaccine or come forward
for your booster you say most people are
wearing masks but i mean looking at the
images from the house of commons the
other day um
i only could see theresa may wearing a
mask on the benches there you go i mean
not many people doing the right thing
there are they um and uh jacob rees-mogg
said you don't need to wear a mask
during debate it's because of the
convivial fraternal spirit within the
conservative party does that mean if you
are
convivial and fraternal you don't get
covered
no i think you know everybody knows that
you can get covered uh from from anybody
um not setting an example though no and
to be honest we didn't throughout much
of the summer not many of us have had
masks on um i mean i had a mask on
yesterday just because again i was
coughing but um and theresa may has had
one all along because she's also um as
matt um diabetic and diabetic um so i
think she she you know and there's
actually a number of people it's not
just theresa may a number of people who
have health concerns and if i sit next
to anybody who has a mask on i always
put a mask on because obviously they're
concerned about themselves but you'll
find more and more as we go into winter
people will be wearing masks but we
shouldn't make it this you know this
sign of virtue or not i mean you know
people have to make sensible choices but
we've been criticized by the labour
party all work war masks in the chamber
but at their conference none of them had
a mask on you know even more people in
and i'll be
and also the fact that you know in
scotland um it's mandatory to wear a
mask on public transport and also within
uh shops so also the case in wales so
they're wrong to do that
i think we've all had you know that it
depends on on on what you want to to say
as a government i mean we've all had
different things from different times
with the devolved governments and we
have it in our plan b you know we have
it in our plan b the very first part of
this interview is what we should be
talking about getting the vaccine
getting the booster
and the mass is is less less relevant
surely well
it is important and it's actually quite
important for for flu and for other
symptoms as well as i say as we get into
winter i think it's more responsibility
to wear a mask to protect other people
it's a social responsibility to get the
vaccine that's the most important thing
you can do get the vaccine get the
booster and then behave sensibly social
distancing the hand washing the mask we
all have those personal responsibilities
and those british people have been
fantastic you know they have been really
really responsible and you know i think
they are more than capable of making the
government's not leading by example well
i don't accept that i mean you saw those
pictures have another quick look at them
ritually um you know we you know none of
just theresa may looked as though she
had her mask on
um yeah
yeah that's that's the the house of
commons you know
as i say i think more people will start
to wear mass as we get into winter i
think that will happen uh but you know
it's not very comfortable sitting there
for hours either in a mask and we know
that the alternative right well that's
why we're all i mean i'm sure everybody
in that picture has been vaccinated and
i'm sure everybody in that picture will
have their booster yeah and to travel
we're told we need to be fully
vaccinated fully vaccinated does that
mean three doses no does that mean you
can't travel unless you've had your
booster
i don't think so that i think the advice
at the moment is the double-jabbed
vaccination but of course that will
evolve over time as you know as as the
third dose comes in but it would be
unreasonable to say right now when we've
only just started the program that uh
yeah and for other countries as well i
mean of course they're trying to to to
to to get this balance but it's two two
doses for now but uh i'm sure as the
vaccine passport type of uh
sort of concept will evolve and there
will be you know if you've had your
booster etcetera because it's not
probably going to be good for next
summer okay
obviously here to talk about uh your um
specialist area care sector job crisis
is how it's been described the care
system faces a tsunami of unmet need
what are you going to do about it yeah
it's my first time honest care minister
so if i could just start by saying a
massive massive thank you to the 1.5
million people who work in social care
we don't say it nearly enough um they
are absolutely brilliant and i've now
met not 1.5 million but many many people
and they just do the most amazing job
and have done all the way through the
pandemic now as i say it's a massive
workforce it's bigger even in the nhs
1.5 million people and it's it does have
challenges all the time because every
year the need grows by one to two
percent as the demographics change in
our country more elderly people more
need so it's this constant battle to
keep enough people coming into social
care and that's one of the reasons the
whole reform agenda that we put forward
and you know that the new levy which is
going to you know deliver on a new
social care system is really important
because we need to professionalize this
workforce it isn't um invested enough in
it doesn't the training's not invested
enough in there's massive churn 40 churn
there's way too
much use of zero hours contracts and
right now they have um you know we've
just announced this
162.5 million pounds to help with short
term between now and march to get extra
capacity in the system extra hours
agency staff etc but long term this is
also a challenge that we need to put on
a much better form but what you're going
to do in the meantime i mean you could
look at the um shortage
occupation list currently only senior
care workers are on that list you could
change that couldn't you we have senior
care workers on that list but i don't
think that's really the answer you know
hooving up everybody else's social media
what are you going to do so we've done
this eyes in short something like we've
done this before so in the pandemic what
we did before was a very similar thing
to what we've announced today so we got
extra capacity in the system with agency
staff thousands of new recruits but also
more people working um more hours so
quite paying for child care in some
cases to enable people to be more
flexible and work a few more hours
you don't
because you've got 1.1 million vacancies
as well in the country for staff so i'm
not saying that it's easy it isn't easy
this money will help but it is a
challenge that we need to put this whole
workforce on a much better footing for
the long term you're not going to change
the shortage care worker list you can
fill those gaps with what we've got in
the country at the moment well we did it
in the pandemic we got extra hours in um
so no the intention is to this money not
a penny if it's been spent today right
we just just announced it that this is
the answer to try and get more people
into the workforce more agencies give a
bit more money for that and just while
i've got you uh 11th of november um
staff must be fully vaccinated to work
in care homes and that's going to cause
another problem for you is that
something that might you might look at
again
well no i mean with the reason we did
that it is a hard decision making
vaccine a condition of uh deployment um
but of course the vulnerable nature of
people in our residential care homes has
meant that we absolutely think that this
is an important thing to do now the care
staff have been absolutely brilliant
about 95 percent of them have come
forward for the first dose we're
encouraging those others some will be
exempt there are some exemptions that
can be selling
if they don't get back double vaccinated
by the 11th of november then they're out
of a job yes that's that's i mean
they'll they'll be moving on to another
job i would imagine but yes that that is
the case and i've spoken to i was in
care homes yesterday and i was talking
to a local council actually about
whether they felt that you know they
they would be able to manage that by and
large there's been a massive response
people know they're dealing with the
most vulnerable people they know the
vaccination makes a massive difference
we all know the winter pressures are
coming we know that there's going to be
challenges nobody is pretending there
isn't so they have done the right thing
okay
it is it is hard um but it's the right
thing to do we're out of time i must let
you go first time as co-minister here
hopefully it won't be the last thanks
very much indeed thank you thanks so
much appreciated